welcome to this video playing Sarah to
straw 2013's is chilly right yeah I
learned some flex during them the world
cup the football world cup or soccer for
the United States why did you why did
then why did they need to call it soccer
couldn't they at least a name it thats a
european football or something soccer
seems really weird okay anyway I'm Jack
and let's see what happens now well this
video is going to be on YouTube during
my holiday so it's been pre-recorded
quite a while before in fact i'm
recording this on the day before the
world cup final between germany and
argentina so we am when you watch this
video you're going to know if Germany
Escott has managed to to get the force
the fourth star as we discuss it here
normally in Germany got the three stars
for winning the world cup three times
and we want the fourth one okay well
chatting about soccer and football
whatever I have probably misplayed that
somewhat my does not look very good miss
time my advanced here cannot play h form
okay I need to get get the King out of
there you know the Queen side is not
very safe but now i miss time my advance
him with g4
now okay i can open that but i need i
need to get get something going ham
right at five maybe
yeah it's still so not very good okay
does the capture here it's not that's
not the end of the world but i want i
want the g file open and at least that's
that's happening okay it's giving up a
pawn i'm going to take it um take this
or not yeah I guess I'll take it I came
he will have some counter play plenty
with Queen B seven I mean counter player
sir he's got some serious threats but
Jim one
there's some way to put a defense maybe
King see to look be one simply queen bee
seven rugby one yeah why not why not
maybe this this isn't so bad I'm not
like he's not having a ton of attacking
pieces Queen a form ok I can go to d3
that's that's not so terrible
okay um can I go f6 Knight takes rook g7
yeah i think i can but he's got queen a
for Queenie voice is a problem maybe I'm
i put this on d3 before he gets it with
a check well now he's playing them mmm
interesting Queen a form but isn't isn't
this strong here let's say I go f6 I can
maybe play gt5
can maybe play g5
I maybe try to exchange this
um
I can go Queen Queen g3 or just queen
and twin see one but you can take here
that's really a bit bit of a nuisance
okay maybe rookie to after Queen a form
well difficult position really is taking
them I can take these six can I not is
some checks time warning okay check
check
Geoff Geoff so don't know if I can can
play for a win here I can try but it's
very risky I can take it I can play
quindi for which I didn't seem
check
takes I've got F goody 5 check check
if you checks again I'm going to take
the draw him you probably can also play
this for win
maybe check check I don't have any time
check
high five is very strong I don't see how
how to avoid us check cm Jeff I would
like to play for one check can I go here
maybe
Quinn Quinn see one maybe hmm check can
now go to d to check yeah now this was
this was far too risky I guess and maybe
it's ok quindi for King at one check
check check check laughs that's right
now maybe could do that I mean it was
Sir it was a very unnerving this
position we're thinking the King running
around so he keep probably has it he has
a draw here Jenny case but check check
check check yeah I still wanted to try
takes eight wrong it's still a drawback
Oh funny yeah this this kind of stuff is
difficult to say night g I've is a draw
because this is this is a wrong nice I
must be very cautious here this is
checkmate one way to lose it so it's
it's probably still a draw check yeah
yeah check HERE widest why this is
winning out with his pawns and i'm not
i'm not in a perpetual him yeah tough to
play he's certainly a certainty had term
had an ok position a computer gives
right a very clear gem plus plus two
amazing Queen g3 here yeah I probably
made some some mistakes yes
wants to go here yeah maybe I was too
afraid of ancestors this is a big big
space advantage yeah of course I'm silly
I'm sorry I totally forgot that the the
Queen yes of course always threatening
made so he has no way to play Queen a
form and this means that he has no way
account to play I was always afraid of
Queen a form hmm yeah then there is
absolutely absolutely no problem here
white is just much better yeah I didn't
didn't see that and played this is
passive check this passive passive way
check okay yeah here here the computer
gives white also baguettes but this is
not really yeah so so easy in in a blitz
game between humans because of whites
every King position okay interesting
game though thanks for watching